Speaker 1: Why don't we speak next
to let's go back to New York City,
a vendor from New York City. You're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Hi. So I have a question
so I really have seeing how Republicans
treat Democrats and the way they see it
to try and legislate Democrats and a government. I
get the impression that the Republicans just want
to be a one party system. They don't want to
have just one. All Republicans and every lead,
every Senate office throughout the country,
legislative Congress, Senate, and they would not
want any Democrats or in office. And that's the
I see. Be getting everything you hear him say the
way they destroy everything. They all progressives
want old legislation. We want all the things we
stand for. It is wrong to have nothing to do
with Democrats and only be Republicans. Yeah.
Speaker 1: You're blowing you're
blowing up, they're a vendor.
Speaker 2: Yeah, so I just hear them talking.
I mean, the way to demonize, you know,
all Democrats and you say that this
is going to be a one party system,
only Democrats, and that's how they see it. But
that's not how America is. And I just think that I
don't do think it's like hypocrisy on their part.
Speaker 1: Well, hold on a second. I don't isn't
aren't Democrats the same? And Democrats would
like to defeat Republicans in every seat as well.
Speaker 2: And I think that Democrats wouldn't
want to be all all Democrat government, I can
see it can mean that the way this country works, I
mean, I guess now the way hyper partizan politics
works, I mean, like that. But you would think that
having a two party system maybe down the road,
you know, three maybe back in the day, we can look
at the founding country. We had multiple parties,
but now it's one in the other. I mean,
everybody wants their party to be in
charge. And yes, yes, everybody wants that.
Speaker 1: I think that's a key point. Everybody
wants their party to be in charge. I think I
don't know that that's unique to Republicans.
Speaker 2: But they want to be like 100 percent.
And I think that they have not one Democrat in
the Senate or House, they'll be OK with that.
Speaker 1: I think Democrats would be fine,
defeating every Republican to.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean,
Speaker 1: Evander, I've got to ask
what's going on in the background,
are you getting texts? Are you playing games
or you want another call while you're on this
one? What's happening there?
Speaker 2: My wife is going
on this. She just texted me. OK.
Speaker 1: All right. A vendor. I love
the call. I love the question. I hope to speak to
you again, my friend. Thanks, Chris. Thank you.
Speaker 2: The noise causes cancer.
Speaker 1: OK, let's go next to Dylan
from Connecticut. Dylan, you're on the air.
Dylan from Connecticut, you're on the air.
Going for the third time, Dylan from Connecticut,
did you want to talk to me? All right, no, Dylan